bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire dédié aux
prédictions contraste et effets
marginaux alors tout d'abord bah je suis
ravi de vous retrouver ça faisait
effectivement longtemps qu'il n'y avait
pas eu de webinaire euh alors on sort du
live sur Youtube pour des formats
peut-être un petit peu plus courts mais
l'idée c'est de pouvoir du coup aborder
des sujets qu'on navait pas encore
abordés par le passé euh et c'est le cas
par exemple aujourd'hui avec cette
thématique autour des effets
marginaux je vais vous partager mon
écran ça sera plus facile pour s'y
retrouver et puis la première chose bah
que je veux vous annoncer c'est
l'évolution euh avec l'arrivée de guide
a depuis maintenant presque un an euh
donc pour celles et ceux qui sont
habitués à webinaire vous avez souvent
des liens qui vous renvoient vers le
site analysir et en fait guidir est une
évolution d'analysir qui a été
entièrement réécrit actualisé mis au
coup du jour euh donc du coup je vous
invite plus plutôt à vous rendre sur
guider en première intention il est plus
à jour avec un code plus propre et un
peu plus récent notamment on utilise le
nouveau pipe der euh et puis bah pour
des thématiques qui ne seraient pas
encore sur guider vous pouvez toujours
vous référer analyser voilà donc avec
une petite nouveauté guider est du coup
écrit avec quarto qui est une évolution
du air Markdown alors aujourd'hui euh ce
que nous allons aborder c'est la
question des prédictions
marginales vous avez tout le chapitre
qu'on va aborder aujourd'hui en fait est
directement
disponible sur guider
euh donc l'idée he c'est que quand on va
faire un modèle statistique notamment
une régression
logistique rarement notre modèle va être
bah les autres ratios c'est un peu
difficile parfois expliquer parce que ce
qu'on va rendre n'est pas dans la dans
la dimension que l'on observe hein euh
et donc la question c'est euh par
exemple comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
traduire la valeur d'un do ratio un
autre ratio de 2 ou unre ratio de 0,5 en
un écart de probabilité c'est tout ici
euh qu'on va pouvoir avoir recours à ce
qu'on appelle de manière globale les
effets marginaux qui tente de traduire
les résultats du modèle dans la
dimension de la variable d'intérêt alors
en fait il y a plusieurs approches dans
la littérature c'est pas toujours euh
uniformisé vous pouvez entendre parler
d'effets marginaux d'effets statistiques
de moyenne marginale de pente marginale
ou d'effet marginaux à la moyenne en
fait il y a beaucoup d'expressions euh
et donc du coup euh et bien ce que vous
pouvez faire si vous voulez y voir un
petit peu plus clair vous avez
différentes références qui vous sont
données euh notamment avec ce billet
d'Andre qui est intitulé marginalia et
qui date de mai 2022 euh dans le casadre
du du champ de r il y a eu plusieurs
packages il y a eu le package effects
notamment une époque qui en fait on
verra c'est pas tout à fait des effets
qu' présentent vous avez imin margins il
y en a plusieurs chacun a des approches
vocabulaire un petit peu différent ici
dans le le cadre de guider et en fait en
se reposant aussi sur le package
bromelpers on va essayer de suivre
plutôt un vocabulaire qui est celui
qu'on retrouve dans marginal effect
alors l'idée en fait hein c'est de dire
qu'on a deux choses spécifiques d'une
part on va pouvoir éventuellement faire
des
prédictions à la moyenne de notre
échantillon et on va parler alors de
prédiction marginale on va y revenir
donc en fait on va réutiliser notre
modèle pour prédire ce que l'on
observerait toute chose égal par
ailleurs et puis lorsqu'on va calculer
une différence entre des prédictions
marginales par exemple entre deux
modalité on va parler d'un contraste
marginal et donc les contrastes
marginaux c'est une différence entre des
prédictions marginales donc entre deux
modalités pour une variable catégorielle
mais parfois aussi de contraste entre
pour une variable continue puisque ça
serait la différence observée lorsqu'on
change notre la la valeur de du
prédicteur par exemple si on augmente de
1 quelle est la différence et ce qu'on
va appeler pente marginale ou ce qui
serait en fait le terme d'effet marginal
au sens strict en fait pour des
variables Contin uniquement c'est ce
qu'on appelle la dérivée partielle de
l'équation de régression pour certaines
valeurs donc en fait c'est c'est un
contraste marginal mais quand on le tend
vers plus de plus en plus petit c'est
pas l'écart en + 1 ou + 5 mais en fait
cette la tangente à ce pointl et en fait
au sens strict un effet marginal c'est
une pente marginale et en fait il ne se
calcule que pour euh
des variables continues
euh alors que pour des variables
catégorielles en fait on est obligé de
revenir sur des contrastes marginaux
alors on va revenir et explorer un peu
tout ça en détail pour cela on va
repartir en fait de donner
d'illustration qui est un modèle de
régression logistique que l'on a déjà
abordé dans dans les webinaires et donc
je reprendre un un modèle qui cherche à
regarder la probabilité de faire du
sport en fonction d'un certain nombre de
var varable vous retrouverez en fait ce
modèle là un petit peu actualisé dans le
chapitre 22 de guit a qui porte sur la
régression logistique binaire et là pour
le moment ce que je vais faire je vais
copier le code du chapitre pour le
recopier dans ma session
r d'accord donc ce code là il va charger
le taille diverse il va charger le
package labeld le package it summary qui
est le package vraiment qu'on va
utiliser pour faire nos statistiques
descriptives je l'avais abordé dans les
derniers web ire et puis en fait guidire
maintenant est vraiment basé sur GT
summary donc on va charger en fait le
jeu de données HDV 2003 du package
questionnaire qui sont donc les données
de l'enquête histoire de vie 2003 on va
faire un peu de recodage sur nos
variables ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va changer la valeur de référence pour
le le sexe en prenant femme comme valeur
de référence on va découper notre âge en
différents groupe d'âge et on va recoder
le niveau d'étude en catégorie plus
simple primaire secondaire technique qui
est supérieur et puis pour chacune de
ces variables là on va leur donner une
étiquette donc tout ça on l'a déjà
abordé dans d'autres webinaires et vous
retrouverez tous ces éléments détaillés
en détail sur guider sur comment recoder
des variables et comment faire notre
régression
logistique on va faire une régression
logistique binaire tout ce qui est le
plus classique hein on va appeler GLM et
donc on va essayer de prédire la
probabilité de faire du sport en
fonction du sexe du groupe d'âge du
niveau d'étude du nombre d'heures
passées devant la télévision
hein donc on appelle family binomial
pour une régression logistique binaire
et ensuite data ég d donc on a le jeu de
données donc je vais on va tout de suite
exécuter tout ça donc là c'est vraiment
juste le point de départ qui nous permet
d'avoir un modèle de régression
logistique et puis on va regarder du
coup bah quels sont les résultats du
modèle de régression logistique he de
manière tout ce qui est plus classique
donc on va le faire faire avec GT
summary avec un
mode donc j'appelle mon modèle je vais
lui passer TB
regression comme c'est un modèle
logistique on va mettre les expos on va
passer les coefficient en
exponentiel histoire
de d'avoir les autes les autres ratios
et puis je vais faire un bold
labels histoire
de voir un tableau propre des
résultats vous voyez on a les
caractéristique hein du modèle donc vous
avez les hommes ont une probabilité un
peu plus élevée de faire du sport que
les femmes avec un a ratio de
1,52 on voit que la pratique d'un sport
diminue avec l'âge puisque les autres
ratios hein sont de plus en plus faibles
donc 18 24 ans est ici la référence on a
0,68 pour les 25 44 0,36 pour les 45 64
ans et 0,27 pour les 65 ans et plus donc
on a une baisse de la pratique du sport
avec l'âge et puis on voit également sur
le niveau d'étude une différence he la
pratique d'in sport augmente avec le
niveau d'étude ce qu'on niveau d'étude
primaire et ici notre référence on est à
un notre ratio de 2,5 pour le secondaire
2,8 pour technique professionnelle 655
pour le niveau supérieur et on monte à
8,54 pour celles et ceux pour chez qui
ça n'a pas été
documenté donc là voilà ce sont nos nos
AES ratios si on veut les représenter de
manière si on veut avoir un graphique
hein plutôt pour les pour les avoir on
peut utiliser le package GG stat encore
une fois donc ce tout est présenté euh
sur git git a et on va faire du coup un
GG
CF modèle on va lui placer notre modèle
et on va faire exponenti é= true et en
fait ça va nous faire le foresplot hein
tout simplement euh donc c'est les mêmes
résultats que l'on avait dans le tableau
hein donc on voit bien ici de manière un
peu plus visible que c'est plus élevé
pour les hommes que la pratique du sport
baisse avec le niveau d'âge augmente
avec le niveau d'étude et puis on voit
que lorsqu'on passe du temps devant la
télévision on a no ratio négatif he pour
chaque heure passer devant télévision on
a une pratique de moins en moins
importante euh du sport petite nouveauté
euh dans la famille des fonctions de
ggkf ggkf model du ggstat on a une
fonction un petit peu plus récente qui
s'appelle ggkf table qui est très
équivalente hein du coup sauf que elle
va nous permettre de présenter en même
temps euh et ben en fait je vais vous
faire un zoom là ce que vous avez c'est
directement euh le tableau de le Forest
plot avec les coefficients mais on vous
rajoute directement sur le côté un
tableau des coefficients donc là on a à
la fois les valeurs numériques des
différents coefficients et puis le
Forest donc c'est une manière plus
facile euh de lire les résultats du
modèle quoi qu'il en soit ici nos
résultats sont présentés
euh sont présentés hein sous la forme de
euh
euh d'autres ratios et on voit bien que
c'est pas toujours évident quand on doit
présenter nos résultats à des non
statisticiens de leur expliquer en fait
à quoi correspondent ces autres ratios
donc il y a un effet mais euh dans tout
ça on voit pas finalement c'est quoi la
probabilité de faire du sport en
fonction de son âge en fonction de son
sexe
d'où l'intérêt
ici de faire ce qu'on va appeler des
prédiction
marginale alors le principe des
prédictions
marginales pour mieux représenter ce qui
se passe ça va se dire on va essayer de
calculer la probabilité de faire du
sport pour une femme et la probabilité
de faire du sport pour un homme et donc
du coup on va exprimer ça en terme de
pourcentage hein donc ça va être plus
facile et on veut faire varier
uniquement le sexe donc on veut que
toute choses soit égal par ailleurs
c'est l'intérêt de faire un
modèle et pour cela on a plusieurs
approches puisque du coup pour nos
prédictions
marginales la question c'est
euh je vais prédire avec mon modèle
qu'est-ce qui se passe à quoi à la
référence à un individu moyen
la première approche pour faire des
prédictions marginales et en fait c'est
ce qu'on va appeler des prédictions
marginales moyennees consiste à se dire
mais qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
avait que des hommes ou que des femmes
mais tout le reste serait identique
alors pour ça je vais reprendre mon jeu
de données sauf que la petite
particularité c'est que dans mon modèle
j'ai quelques variables manquantes et en
fait si on regarde mon modèle mon jeu de
donnée d il a
euh att on va faire un N ça ça sera plus
facile mon jeu de donnée d j'ai 1000
individus mais en fait dans mon modèle
je n'en ai pas 1000 je n'en ai que euh
un un peu un nombre un peu moins 1994 il
est affiché ici pourquoi parce que 1995
individus parce qu' il y a CIN
observations qui ont été retiré car
elles sont manquantes donc ce que
j'aimerais récupérer c'est juste le jeu
de données qui a servi au modèle alors
une petite astuce c'est ce qu'on appelle
le model frame hein qui est euh euh du
jeu de données donc en fait je vais
aller récupérer modèle frame de mon
modèle là je vous fais de manière
générique et vous avez du coup
maintenant ici un objet MF qui a en fait
euh
1995 observation donc en fait le le
model frame d'un modèle dans R en fait
ça correspond au jeu de données qui a
réellement servi au niveau du modèle euh
donc là j'ai mon jeu hein c'est donc
c'est mes observations qui sont
complètes tout simplement on a retiré
les observations manquantes maintenant
supposons que je n'ai que des femmes ou
que des
hommes donc je vais faire une
copie je vais faire une copie de
MF sauf que je vais
dire je vais je vais transformer la
variable sexe pour qu'il n'y ait plus
que des
femmes et je vais faire de la même
manière un jeu de
données où il n'y aurait que des
hommes donc la particularité c'est que
dans tous les cas j'ai 1995 individus
ces individus ont la même distribution
par âge la même distribution du niveau
d'étude et la même distribution du
nombre d'heures passé devant la
télévision par
jour que mon échantillon hein donc d'une
certaine manière en fait je je garde mon
même échantillon observé mais je fais
l'hypothèse que tout le monde est une
femme ou que tout le monde est un homme
et en fait à partir de ce moment-là on
va pouvoir essayer de prédire finalement
c'est quoi la probabilité de faire du
sport et pour ça on a la fonction
predict hein donc si je passe si je pars
de mon modèle et que je lui applique
prédicte je vais mettre l'option type
égal response en fait çaà dire que je
veux appliquer mon modèle pour prédire
la probabilité he donc on est sur sur
l'échelle euh d'observer donc typical
response et puis je vais lui indiquer un
nouveau jeu de données avec new data et
je vais appliquer mon jeu de données new
data é= MF
FAM ce que j'obtiens en fait c'est pour
chacune de mes observations donc pour
mes 1995 observations la probabilité de
faire du
sport ce qui est pas forcément donc du
coup on l'a en fait hein c'est ce que
dit le modèle pour chacun de ces 1995
individus qu est la probabilité de faire
le sport ce qu'on va regarder c'est tout
simplement la moyenne ce qui est un peu
plus simple et donc ici j'ai si je
reprends mon échantillon que je garde ma
distribution par âge et par niveau
d'étude et par heure passer devant la
télévision mais que je considère que
tout le monde est une femme alors en
moyenne le modèle va prédire que 32 %
des individus font du sport je vais
refaire la même prédiction mais pour les
hommes cette
fois-ci
d'accord et cette fois-ci on obtient 40
% dans mes deux prédictions tout est
identique c'est le même modèle c'est la
même distribution par âge par niveau
d'étude et par heure de télévision la
seule chose qui change c'est que dans un
cas on aurait que des femmes et dans
l'autre cas on aurait que des hommes
donc en fait qu'on c'est ça qu'on va
appeler une prédiction marginale moyenne
parce qu'on a fait une moyenne de
prédiction
marginale en fait et là ce que l'on a
donc 40 % versus 3% ça nous donne en
fait ce que traduit C ratio de
1,5 ça nous donne cette prédiction
moyenne et donc du coup on voit bien y a
un écart de points grosso modo entre les
femmes et les
hommes à la moyenne des autres
variable en fait pour obtenir ce même
résultat là là je me suis embêté à le
faire on peut le faire avec le package
marginal effect que je vais charger
qui permet de faire ce calcul
là avec sa fonction qui s'appelle
prediction donc on appelle prediction
donc je passe mon modèle moi je vais
faire une prédiction sur la variable sex
et je veux les résultats par
sex attention je me trompe pas dans mes
fermetures et on va
rajouter le type respon c'est pour dire
qu'on fait le on fait le calcul non on
fait sur le le le renvoi de pas sur la
prédiction interne du modèle mais bien
sur la on repasse la fonction le kit
inversé pour revenir en pourcentage et
puis voilà là ce que je vais faire c'est
une prédiction sur la variable sexe et
je le veux pour chacune des valeurs de
sexe et si je fais cette commande là
voyez j'obtiens ce qu'on avait tout à
l'heure c'est 32,5 versus 40,4 donc par
défaut en fait il va dupliquer mon jeu
de données pour chacune des variables de
sexe et va ne faire varier que la valeur
de
sexe on pourrait faire des choses un peu
plus compliquées dans les prédictions
mais c'est
vraiment la situation de base quand on
veut faire des prédictions pour une
variable continue par exemple si je
voulais voir qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
he télé par
défaut on va le faire
prédiction donc je veux faire des
prédictions pour la variable continue
donc c'est
RTV pour différentes valeurs de
RTV et encore une
fois type égal response alors comme
c'est une variable continue on va pas
avoir des prédictions qui se font pour
des catégories mais pour certaines
valeurs particulières de he télévision
là on voit que quand on regarde pas la
télévision et s'il y avait que ça qui
change et ben si tout le SI regarder la
télévision le modèle préd prédit une
pratique du sport de 41 % qui descend à
39 % si on regarde 1 heure de télévision
par par jour euh qui descend à 36 % si
on en regarde 2h 34 % si regarde 3h et
16 % si on regarde 12h alors en fait les
les les valeurs qui sont proposées par
défaut ici hein c'est ce qu'on appelle
les CIN nombres de Tuquet c'est-à-dire
le minimum le premer quartil la médiane
le 3ème quartil et le
maximum donc en fait tout ça he on voit
avec marginal effects on peut faire du
coup ses prédictions pour chacune de nos
variables l'intérêt que fournit Brom
helpers he donc je le rappelle Brom
helpers c'est un petit package qui est
utilisé à la fois par GT Suar et par
pour faire les TB regression ou par gg7
pour faire en fait les graphiques euh
bromelpers propose une fonction tid
marginal prediction euh et qui permet en
fait d'avoir
directement euh
bah sans avoir à codé pour chacune des
variables il va nous proposer par
définition tout de suite eu si je fais
tid
marginal prediction et je vais lui
passer du coup mon
modèle en fait ça va me le calculer en
fait pour chacune de mes variables
donc en fait ça va faire le calcul pour
sexe pour le groupe d'âge pour le niveau
d'étude et pour le nombre d'heures
passées devant la
télévision avec du coup ici l'estimation
j'ai juste oublié de préciser ici le
type égal
response je le refais au propre et on
retrouve bien notre 32 % 40 % la
comparaison des hommes et des femmes là
on l'a pour chacune des modalités de de
de classe et donc grâce à ça le fait
qu'on a un tider qui envoie directement
un tableau propre et ben on peut en
faire du coup tout de suite un tableau
des prédictions magchinales avec TB
regression donc on prend notre modèle on
passe jusqu'à TB regression on va y dire
que la fonction pour mettre en forme et
ben c'est pas la la fonction tid par
défaut qui renvoie les résultats du
modèle mais
tid marginal prediction et du coup ça va
récupérer directement les prédictions
marginales on va ajouter type égal
response puisque pour là on est sur des
prédictions marginales on veut le la
réponse et si je fais ça j'obtiens
directement un tableau de mes
prédictions marginales alors peut-être
une toute petite précision ce qu'on
aimerait c'est avoir des pourcentages
affichés là et plutôt que les 0,32 donc
je peux l'améliorer avec estimate fun et
là je vais appeler la fonction
scills la belle percent qui va pouvoir
me me mettre euh en
pourcentage et je vais préciser
accuracy égal 0 point pour avoir du coup
des pourcentage avec une
décimale concernant les fonctions de
mise en forme euh sur la mise en forme
des nombres sur guidire vous avez un
chapitre dédié qui est le chapitre 15
sur la mise en forme des nombres donc
euh je je reviens pas trop ici ça avait
déjà été abordé mais mais retenez hein
qu'on peut facilement mettre en mettre
en forme et donc on a du coup ici une
prédiction marginale avec en même temps
euh un intervalle de confiance à 95 %
qui est calculé pour chacune de ces
prédictions marginales et vous avez une
pvaleur alors la p-valeur ici elle est
euh elle est un peu bizarre parce que du
coup en fait ce qu'elle représente c'est
dans quelle mesure le pourcentage est
différent de 50 %. euh ce qui ne nous
intéresse pas trop dans le cas présent
donc on a tout un quand on fait des
prédictions marginales on n pas besoin
de tester si la prédiction est
différente des 50 % à part dans certains
cas donc on va utiliser modify
colum pour masquer du coup C p valeurs
qui ne font pas trop sens et puis pour
rendre le tableau plus joli on peut
faire un B labels qui permet du coup de
mettre en gras le nom des variables et
donc voyez on a ici tout de suite nos
prédictions
marginales
donc ça permet de voir et de traduire en
fait ce que nous dit le modèle ce que
nous dit le modèle en prédiction
marginale moyenne c'est que si il y
avait que des femmes dans l'échantillons
on aura observé 32 et toute autre chose
égale par ailleurs on aurait observé 32
% de pratique du sport versus 40 % en
fait c'est la traduction de ce que
représente notre ratio de tout à l'heure
qu'on avait
observé alors on peut aussi avoir envie
de représenter ça
sous la forme de graphique Brom helpers
propose une fonction qui s'appelle plot
marginal
prediction donc dans bromelpers où je
lui faire type ég response et puis on va
lui passer notre
modèle en
amont ce qui se passe c'est qu'en fait
c'est que ça me renvoie quatre
graphiques un pour chacune des variables
donc si en fait on les veut euh on
souhaite les voir tous ensemble on aura
intérêt à les combiner ce qu'on peut
faire facilement avec patchwork
euh
wrap plots d'accord donc là ça va nous
permettre de mettre
euh directement tous nos graphiques les
uns à côté des autres donc là c'est sur
le fait de combiner euh différents
graphiques c'est aussi aborder
normalement sur guider euh et donc
graphique avec dans le chapitre 17
graphique avec GG plot 2 on vous parle
de la combinaison des graphiques he
comment mettre plusieurs graphiques les
uns avec les autres donc là vous avez
une représentation graphique en fait de
de nos prédictions marginales peut-être
ce qu'on peut faire pour essayer de
l'améliorer c'est voyez les échelles
sont pas les mêmes partout et donc du
coup je vais utiliser le avec patchwork
si j'applique en fait
le j'applique à l'opérateur et ça va me
permettre d'ajouter un élément à chacun
des différents graphiques et qui sont en
fait des graphiques GG 2 donc je vais
appliquer une échelle mais à chacun des
CAD sous graphique en indiquant bah je
vais indiquer les limites donc là entre
0 et 80 % 08 et puis pareil je vais
mettre des étiquettes qui va être skills
level perc encore une fois on va
utiliser des
pourcentages et vous voyez là j'ai la
même échelle sur les quatre donc on peut
voir vraiment l'effet des différentes
variables et pour la variable continue
qui est heure de télévision on voit bien
en fait comment les choses penchent vers
le bas hein donc on voit que on a une
pratique du sport autour de 40 % qui
diminue toute chos égal par ailleurs
avec l'augmentation du nombre d'heures
passées devant la télévision on voit la
différence hom femme et puis on voit
bien l'augmentation par le niveau
d'étude et l'évolution ici en fonction
de
l'âge alors ça c'est une des
représentations graphiques possi euh si
on va avoir un peu plus d'espace pour
pouvoir lire correctement ce qui se
passe ici on peut inverser du coup les
coordonnées et là par exemple j'ai
rajouté un cord flip qui va me permettre
de passer en fait l'axe des X et des y
ce qui permet d'avoir du coup plus de
latitude pour lire hein les les
différentes modalités mais c'est vrai
que du coup pour le nombre d'heures
passé devant la télévision c'est un peu
plus dur peut-être à à à voir l'effet
pour une variable
quantitative et puis enfin euh on a
aussi la possibilité de faire le
graphique avec GG stat puisque ggstat
fonctionne aussi avec Broom helpers et
on peut aussi lui passer du coup euh une
fonction une ta def fun donc du coup je
peux prendre mon modèle appeler euh ggkf
model
ou même un ggkf table hein si on a envie
euh ça fonctionne et ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va indiquer que tid fun du
coup c'est cette fonction tid marginal
prediction il va falloir quand même lui
indiquer qu'on veut le type response
alors on peut pas directement le
rajouter il
faut passer en fait par tidy ARS he les
les pour GG stat en fait pour rajouter
un dans TBL regression le type response
est transmis automatiquement à T
marginal prediction là avec GG stat en
avec GGF model par il faut en fait
indiquer les éléments à transférer
simplement avec une liste d'arguments
qu'on va passer à ta defun donc là on va
passer le type ég
respon et je peux avoir directement du
coup
euh mon graphique et puis on peut
éventuellement effacer he les pvaleurs
on a dit qu'on les voulait pas donc je
vais rajouter show pvue ég
false sinif stars égal F pour retirer en
fait euh et
là significance ég nul donc ça je retire
les paramètres qui était autour des
autour des pvaleurs dans dans dans dans
mon modèle et voyez je récupère du coup
un graphique avec les prédictions
marginales là encore une fois on
pourrait rajouter euh des pourcentages
sur l'échelle horizontale donc
éventuellement avec un scale
x continuous et on va simplement
indiquer que la BS égal scales label
percent pour avoir un graphique
propre donc là on a notre graphique qui
est plutôt
propre et on peut même essayer de faire
ça avec
ggftable normalement ça devrait
marcher c'est ici faut que je supprime
peut-être cet aspect
là
voilà et on peut faire un ggcftable la
particularité c'est qu'on aura d'autres
petits twak pour arriver à passer les
résultats sur du pourcentage hein mais
les les deux
fonctionnent je vais revenir sur le ggcf
model de base donc vous voyez ça c'est
ce qu'on
appelle
euh c'est ce qu'on appelle du coup des
prédictions marginales moyennes en
anglais average marginal prediction hein
on est du coup dans le cas de figure
euh où on va dupliquer le jeu de données
reprendre toutes les observations du jeu
de données et simplement faire varier
une des modalités et ensuite on fait la
moyenne de toutes les
prédictions alors petite précision en
fait avec pour les modèles en fait GLM
et cet argument type he qu'on a vu c'est
quand on a des modèles calculés avec GLM
on peut réaliser des prédictions selon
deux échelles l'échelle de l'outcome
c'est le type ég response c'està-dire là
en probabilité en pourcentage mais on
peut aussi faire une prédiction selon
l'échelle
euh de la fonction de lien he puisquon a
on a une fonction lit et on peut faire
un type égal Link qui est la fonction
logit techniquement donc en fait voilà
on peut choisir ces deux types de
prédiction
euh et
puis il peut y avoir dans des versions
récentes de marginal effects en fait si
on précise pas le paramètre Type ou par
défaut ce qui est fait en fait c'est que
les les prédictions sont faites sur
l'échelle de lien moyenné sur l'échelle
de lien puis seulement retransformer
selon l'inverse en pourcentage et donc
du coup dans ce cas-là vous avez un
résultat qui est un petit peu différent
hein parce que si jamais ici je ne
précise
pas le type égal response hein vous
verrez les prédictions vont être
légèrement vont être légèrement
différentes et ça c'est c'est lié au
fait qu'il y a deux deux petites
manières de calculer donc gardez le type
égal link euh euh et et au besoin vous
retrouverez dans le chapitre
euh sur les prédictions marginales la la
la la petite prédiction sur le prix qui
vous explique en fait c'est ces nuances
là tout est expliqué là donc n'hésitez
pas en fait il y a pas besoin de retenir
tout d'un chapitre d'une vidéo mais de
d'être en capacité de savoir que s'il y
a besoin on pourra retrouver une
précision alors là nous avons en fait vu
des prédictions marginalement moyenne
c'est-à-dire que nous avons fait des
prédictions pour chaque observation du
tableau d'origine en faisant varier
juste une variable à la fois avant de
calculer la moyenne des prédictions il y
a une alternative qui consiste à générer
une sorte d'individu moyen ou typique et
puis à réaliser des prédictions
uniquement pour cet unique individu et
on parle alors de prédiction marginale à
la
moyenne donc prédiction marginale
moyenne on prend tous les individus et
on fait la moyenne sur tous les
individus
prédiction marginale à la moyenne on va
essayer de trouver un individu qui
serait moyen et de calculer le
prédiction à cette
moyenne alors ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que tous les pack pas forcément la même
approche avec marginal effect on peut le
faire et donc dans ce cas on va
utiliser on va simplement faire no
prédictions reprendre mon code de
prédiction voilà
donc si on faire des prédictions
marginales à la
moyenne on vaaire notre
prédiction mais on va on peut simplement
dire se ça va être suffisant
mais on va indiquer
newg
min et donc dans ce CASL
ce que va faire marginal effect il va
considérer pour chaque variable continue
sa moyenne par exemple pour he TV va
considérer 2,25 parce que 2,25 c'est la
moyenne dans l'ensemble de
l'échantillon et
ensuite pour les variables catégorielles
il va considérer le
mode le mode c'est la variable la plus
fréquente le groupe d'âge le plus
représenté dans l'échantillon ce sont
les 45 64 an donc du coup on va prendre
individu qui est qui a 45 64 ans le
niveau d'étude le plus courant c'est
technique professionnel le nombre moyen
passé devant le la télévision c'est 2,25
et puis il va calculer on va faire
varier uniquement le sexe et donc pour
une femme qui passerait 2,25 he devant
la télévision qu'un qui a 45 64 ans et
qui est d'un niveau technique
professionnel sa probabilité de faire du
sport est de 24 % 23,9 et pour un homme
c'est c'est 32,3 donc l'idée c'est qu'on
fait varier que notre variable sex mais
cette fois-ci au lieu de prendre tout
l'échantillon et de faire une prédiction
pour tout l'échantillon on va et on va
juste considérer un individu moyen et
par défaut ce que fait marginal effect
il prend comme individu moyen la moyenne
pour les variables continues et le mode
pour les variables euh
catégorielles ça c'est donc du coup une
des
approches et comme tout à l'heure on va
pouvoir faire un tableau ou un graphique
he si je veux faire en fait
euh le tableau avec TB
regression je vais reprendre du
coup et ici on va simplement passer un
new data égal
min et en passant new data ég min on
aura du coup les prédictions marginales
à la moyenne vous avez vu que quand on
fait ça avec TB regression euh en fait
c'est que T marginal prediction c'estd
les fonctions de bromelpers qui sont
utilisé par par tbel reguration repère
le type de prédiction que vous faites et
vous voyez que le titre en haut il est
ajusté en
conséquence donc la prédiction marginale
à la moyenne selon
marginal le package marginal effectex
qu'on obtient avec la fonction tid
marginal prediction la moyenne les
individus moyens c'est bien la moyenne
pour les autres les variables continues
le mode
pour les variables
euh pour les variables
catégorielles il y a un autre package
que vous avez peut-être déjà croisé qui
est présent depuis très longtemps dans
dans R c'est le package Effects et le
package effect lui euh alors il
s'appelle effect mais en fait il calcule
pas des effets marginaux il calcule des
prédictions marginales hein donc
attention à la vocabulaire hein le
package effect malgré son nom ne calcule
pas des effets marginaux mais bien des
prédictions marginales si on se remet
dans la terminologie qu'on que l'on a
vu je vais charger effect et l'idée
c'est qu'il faut arriver à comprendre ce
que fait
effect donc je vais calculer ça c'est
avec la fonction
effect alors pour la variable sex en
utilisant le modèle mode
voyons voir ce que ça donne notre objet
e hein il fait une prédiction de 28 %
pour les femmes et de 38 % pour les
hommes on est aussi sur une production
marginale la question c'est de
comprendre finalement mais c'est quoi
notre individu moyen auquel est calculer
d'accord on a fait varier homme-femme
mais c'est quoi les valeurs qu'on a pris
pour les autres variables et ça on peut
les voir en fait avec en regardant un
peu en profondeur dans l'objet on a un
objet modèle matrix à à l'intérieur et
en fait ce qu'on voit euh c'est qu'il a
utilisé pour chacune des variables
catégorielles leur proportion
observé en fait il considèent l'individu
moyen comme étant un individu qui est à
35 % entre 25 et 44 ans à 37 % entre 45
et 64 ans et à 19 % entre 65 ans et plus
donc en fait notre individu moyen c'est
une prédiction marginale moyenne sauf
que l'individu moyen dans qu'à présent
euh pour les variables catégorielles il
est composé des différentes
modalités et qui correspondent
finalement à la représentation de ces
différentes modalités donc on a quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus proche de
cette notion d'individu moyen que ce
qu'on a avec marginal effect
euh et en fait on peut aussi faire le
tableau parce qu'on a dans bromelpers la
fonction tid tid all
effect et donc dans ce cas-là en fait on
va simplement refaire le tableau en
appelant cette fois-ci tid all effects
comme fonction tid de pour de
préparation des données euh on n pas
besoin du new data et là nous avons du
coup hop j'ai pas l'pai valeur à
cacher il en a pas de calculer et là du
coup on a des prédictions marginales à
la moyenne calculer avec le package
effect d'accord donc vous voyez c'est
pas les mêmes prédictions marginale
moyenne que tout à l'heure marginal
effect prenait le mode pour les
variables catégorielles là où effect
prend pour les Var catégorie une
combinaison finalement de tel qu'observé
dans l'échantillon donc c'est un petit
peu c'est un peu plus proche encore une
fois on est sur tous des prédictions
marginales moyennne c'est juste que ell
correspondent pas tout à
fait voyez on a plusieurs manières de
les
calculer et bien sûr on peut aussi en
faire une représentation graphique euh
d'une part parce que naturellement on
peut faire
euh on peut faire notre modèle appliquer
la fonction all
effect de
euh de du package effectx et ensuite
appliquer un plot et avec ça on a
directement le graphique de tous les
effets alors présenter un peu
différemment hein mais vous l'avez là et
puis vous retrouvez sur chapitre
analyser on peut aussi très bien appeler
ggkf.tl avec tid effect pour en faire
une représentation sachez enfin dans la
représentation graphique il y a aussi le
package ggffs qui propose une fonction
GG effect qui permet de faire en fait de
représenter la même chose que ce qu'on a
là calculé avec le package effect et
puis enfin dans les variantes GGF c'est
aussi une fonction GG prédiic qu'on peut
utiliser euh où là en fait on utilise
pour les variables catégoriel la
euh la modalité de référence hein vous
savez que dans nos mod on a mis une
référence pour certaines modalités et
bien on peut aussi calculer une
prédiction à la référence alors c'est
plus une prédiction marginale moyenne
c'est une prédiction marginale à la
référence pour les variables
catégorielles pour les variables
continue on reste encore la
moyenne et donc du coup alors c'est
pareil on reprend fait le même code
simplement on va appeler
tid GG
predict
et en fait on obtient ici des
prédictions marginales à la référence
c'est-à-dire qu'on va considérer dans ce
modèle là la référence était 18 24 ans
niveau primaire et pour les variables
bah continu la référence est zéro et
donc du coup en fait on est à la
référence 24 % chez les femmes 32 % chez
les hommes hein donc là ce sont des
prédictions uniquement à la référence
donc vous voyez c'est encore un petit
peu différent à l'usage je vous avoue
moi j'utilise quasiment uniquement les
prédictions marginales moyennes parce
qu'en fait il s'agit de reprendre
finalement tout notre échantillon on
considère que tout reste inchanger
simplement on fait varier qu'un curseur
et une variable à la fois et on a ces
prédictions
là alors maintenant qu'on a
nos nos prédictions marginale en fait on
va pouvoir aborder du coup cette notion
de contraste
marginaux he donc l'idée avec les
contrastes marginaux c'est maintenant
qu'on a ses prédictions marginales bah
quelle est la différence entre deux
modalités d'accord euh et ben pour ça on
va repartir d'un exemple concret hein
revenons et on va voir on a les
contrastes marginaux moyens les
contrastes marginaux à la moyenne he
selon la même logique donc jeis revenir
sur mes prédictions marginales à la
moyenne d'accord donc on va les refaire
on va faire le calcul de base avec la
fonction
prédiction de marginal effect pour on va
partir de notre
modèle la variable ça va être
Sex on ve le faire pour chaque valeur de
sex et on va faire notre type égal
response donc ça si on revient c'est nos
prédictions marginales hein et je vais
les réafficher euh
pardon du coup c'était nos prédictions
marginale moyenne hein de tout à l'heure
32 % pour les femmes 40 % pour les
hommes bah du coup on peut s'intéresser
à à la différence entre les deux hein
donc jeis prends l'estimation des hommes
moins
l'estimation des femmes en fait faire 40
% 32 % on obtient du coup ce 7,8 % 8 %
en fait c'est l'écart qui entre les
hommes et les femmes les hommes sont 8
point au-dessus des femmes et bien ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle le contraste
marginal et en fait donc contraste on
peut parler aussi de comparaison et on
peut le le calculer en fait
avec la fonction AVG comparison de
marginal effect et donc là on va
indiquer la
variable sex là on a la le contraste
hommees moins femm d'accord donc hommes
moins femme on a un écart de + 7
%. donc en fait c'est cette différence
là donc les contrastes marginaux sont
simplement une différence
entre deux
modalités si on met une variable
quantitative c'est un petit peu
différent vous allez voir ici euh là je
fais pour he TV il va en fait me
retraduire ce qui se passe et là le
contraste par défaut c'est + 1 donc
c'est si j'augmente de 1 le nombre
d'heures passées devant la télévision
alors mon pourcentage baisse de deux
points hein de
0,0227 donc en pourent de 2,27 %. donc à
chaque fois que je passe une heure
devant la télévision on est à euh 2,227
euh en fait plus précisément c'est la
différence voilà euh qu'on peut faire
avec AVG comparé avec comparison si vous
le voulez plutôt que d'avoir un écart de
1 vous pouvez demander pour un écart de
10 ou pour un écart de 3 tout est
parfaitement euh personnalisable euh
l'intérêt en fait c'est que on peut euh
bah faire un tableau très facilement
avec ça je vais prendre mon tableau là
des prédictions des prédictions
marginales moyennes qu'on avait fait
tout à l'heure
euh il est
là donc là je là je vous voyez je vous
montre le code détaillé he du calcul
pour cont pour essayer de comprendre ce
qu' joue mais vous voyez que pour faire
les tableaux ça peut être beaucoup plus
simple et pour faire directement ça pour
toutes les variables et ben on va faire
tout simplement le
tid marginal
contrast euh je garde mon
euh et vous voyez là ça m'affiche à %
pour les hommes - 84 euh et là on voit
que entre des 25 44 ans et les 1824 il y
a un écart de 8 % entre les 45 64 et les
18 24 il y a un écart de 21 %. donc là
par défaut il nous a fait les écart hein
pour chacune des modalités à la
référence petite précision moi quand je
fait des différences j'aime bien ficher
un signe plus pour les valeurs positives
et donc dans label percent on peut
rajouter style positive
égal plus juste pour qu'on ait ce petit
symbole pour son devant et puis enfin
cette fois-ci j'ai plus besoin de cacher
ma pvaleur parce que la pvaleur pour les
contraste elle devient plus intéressante
elle nous dit est-ce que le contraste il
est différent de
zéro d'accord et donc là on a clairement
quelque chose qui est qui qui est plus
efficace et puis de la même manière on
peut représenter hein les contrastes
euh avec un GG CF avec un GG stat hein
donc si je
fais mode GG CF modèle cette fois-ci on
va passer du coup
Tun c'est donc du coup
tid marginal
contrast et si je fais
ça
j'ai un graphique de mes contrastes hein
et qui permet en fait de traduire donc
en fait ça ressemble à notre forplot
c'est jusque là les différence exprimé
en pourcentage he c'est des différences
de pourcentage entre des modalités hein
donc on n plus à comparer une référence
on est en train de comparer
euh avec les modalités alors juste pour
vous montrer si je reviens sur le
chapitre euh guidire je vais aller sur
les contrastes marginaux
euh
donc là sur no contrastes marginaux
moyens en fait il y a des on peut
personnaliser un certain nombre de
contrastes qui sont présentés parce que
là on a fait vous voyez par défaut ce
qui a été ce qui est ce qui a été fait
ici par défaut en fait chacune des
modalités était comparé à la modalité de
référence en fait à la première modalité
des variables catégorielles vous avez en
fait des options comme pairwise qui
permett de faire toutes les
combinaisonsz la 18 les 25 44 18 24 les
45 64 18 24 les 45 ans et plus au 25 44
VO on a toutes les combinaisons
possibles euh vous avez aussi euh le le
mode séquentiel donc c'est-à-dire quand
je vais comparer le secondaire au
primaire puis euh le technique
professionnel au secondaire puis le
supérieur technique au euh au technique
professionnel donc on les fait étape par
étape euh et vous avez aussi des
modalités euh on peut aussi indiquer euh
une autre valeur pour une variable
continue
si je fais liste heure pointv é= 2 là
j'ai la différence pour un écart de 2h
donc on peut personnaliser tout ça
euh hein et on a du coup des
euh voilà on a on a plus d'options qui
qui qui vous sont présentées ici
d'accord donc ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que les contrastes marginaux moyen
en fait c'est simplement les écarts par
rapport à nos prédictions marginales
moyennes hein he et une fois qu'on a
compris les deux c'est deux manières
différentes euh quand on fait des
prédictions marginales moyennes c'est
toujours intéressant parce que avoir ce
graphique hein et ce ce souvenir alors
je pense notamment
à pas le tableau mais vraiment euh on va
le refaire le le graphique avec plot
marginal contast alors il était
euh plot marginal prediction hein quel
que soit modèle quand vous faites euh
alors je vais retirer le cord flip mais
quand vous faites ce graphique là ça
vous permet quand même bien de voir
l'effet de chacune des variables et
comment ça joue là je vois tout de suite
l'effet sur l'âge l'effet sur le niveau
d'étude donc de toute façon même si vous
le mettez pas dans une publication avoir
ce graphique des des des prédictions
marginales moyennes ça permet de
d'interpréter correctement le modèle et
on le reverra en particulier euh sur les
interactions euh on pourra revoir
euh euh pour revoir la question des
interactions avec ces prédictions
marginales ça permet de bien comprendre
ce qui est en train de se jouer les
contrastes marginaux eux ils ont un
intérêt quand vraiment on a besoin de
faire des comparaisons re catégories
l'intérêt des prédictions marginales
c'est que là il y a pas la comparaison
hein donc je peux dire celui-là est plus
grand celui-là est plus petit ça évite
d'avoir à chercher quelle est la
modalité de
référence et puis le dernier point que
je veux aborder donc là on a vu
prédiction marginale moyenne contraste
marginaux moyen mais on peut faire aussi
comme on pouvait faire des prédictions
marginales à la moyenne faire des
contrastes marginaux à la moyenne en
fait c'est le le le le même principe et
en fait simplement bah on va repasser ce
new data égal m he donc ça on peut le
faire à la moyenne on n pas la
possibilité de faire les contrastes
marginaux à la technique du package
effect hein mais on a ici à la moyenne
puis enfin vous avez les pentes
marginales O ce qu'on appelle les effets
marginaux au sens strict en fait qui est
vraiment l'effets marginaux en fait pour
ça on va passer par la fonction AVG slop
de marginal effect mais qu'on peut et
vous avez un tid AVG slop la différence
en fait c'est que c'est très proche de
vos contrastes marginaux he si je
reviens sur les contrastes marginaux
qu'on avait à la moyenne euh pour
hertv on trace marginau pour TV voyez on
était à moins de 3 et si je fais la
pente
moyenne la pente euh
elle est de 2,3 donc en fait c'est à peu
près équivalent c'est juste qu'on l'
calculé sur un tout petit peu en fait ce
qui se passe on prend la moyenne et on
rajoute
01 donc un tout petit peu et on voit la
pente et on ramène de toute façon ce
calcule là à un écart de 1 donc c'est
assez proche c'est juste que matiquement
c'est un peu différent les pentes
marginales au sens strict n ne sont pas
définis pour des variables catégorielles
et donc en fait ce que fait marginal
effect c'est que pour les variables
catégorielles ça renvoie des contrastes
marginaux hein donc en fait c'est
vraiment très très proche donc ce que
vous pouvez retenir c'est que euh les
prédictions marginales vous permettent
de savoir
euh vous permettre en fait de de
réexprimer les résultats de votre modèle
dans la dimension du modèle si c'est un
mod une régression logistique c'est
exprimé en pourcentage si vous faites un
modèle de poisson ça ça va être exprimé
en nombre de en comptage hein donc ça
permet de réexprimer en fait les
résultats du modèle dans la dimension de
de du phénomène que l'on étudie tout en
ayant ces expressions toute chose égal
par ailleurs et vraiment ces prédictions
marginales alors moi je vais plutôt
utiliser prédiction marginal moyenne
mais vous pouvez aussi faire des
prédiction marginale à la moyenne dans
tous les cas réexprimer ça ça permet au
moins pour soi de bien interpréter ses
coefficients et éviter les erreurs donc
vraiment je vous invite à faire toujours
le graphique de vos prédictions
marginales moyenne
euh hein ce ce ce ce type de graphique
là il est vraiment essentiel pour bien
interpréter les résats de son modèle et
ça évite vraiment les contresens et euh
dans une publication scientifique
souvent je vais présenter un forest plot
ou les coefficients du modèle de plus en
plus maintenant quand même on voit dans
les publications récentes on va avoir
des présentations soit de prédiction
marginale moyenne soit de contrastes
marginaux
euh mais par exemple pour des
présentations par exemple des non
académiques lorsque l'on va euh parce
que de plus en plus en tant que
chercheur on doit aussi on se doit aussi
d'aller présenter nos résultats à des
non techniciens donc on va pas présenter
des choses aussi complexes à notre ratio
ça va pas parler à des gens qui sont pas
habitués à ce que c'est et donc on a
plutôt intérêt à présenter en fait euh
euh plutôt ce type de graphique là parce
que c'est exprimé en pourcentage et là
si j'ai dit bah voilà on pratique de
moins en moins du sport lorsque l'on
vieillit et toute chose égale par
ailleurs on est à peu près à 50 %
lorsqu'on a 18 ans et on est autour de
27 % lorsqu'on a 65 ans et plus tout
d'un coup ça parle beaucoup mieux et
c'est plus facile du coup à se
représenter hein donc ça aide aussi à ça
c'est prédiction marginal les contrastes
marginaux ils sont vraiment intéressants
lorsqu'on a besoin de mettre des écarts
entre modalités euh euh et il faut se
rendre compte on peut utiliser les deux
he si on fait ses contrastes marginaux
ses prédictions marginales euh vraiment
de la même manière c'està-dire tous les
deux moyenne ou tous les deux à la
moyenne euh avec la même technique on
peut les mettre en regard par exemple on
peut tout à fait interpréter en disant
bah voilà on est à 30 % chez les femmes
30 % chez les hommes soit plus 8 % et
avec un écart qui est significatif P
inférieur à 001 puisqu'on a du coup
aussi la pvaleur associée à l'élément si
vous présentez des contrastes marginaux
ou des prédictions marginales dans un
article surtout je vous invite à mettre
en annexe en supplementary materials le
tableau détaillé avec les autres ratios
et les coefficients du modèle c'est
toujours une bonne pratique euh mais
voilà sachez que en tout cas on en parle
de plus en plus de ces prédictions
marginales de ces contrastes marginaux
ou de ses effets marginaux soyez
vigilant au fait que euh bah d'un auteur
à l'autre c'est pas
toujours c'est pas toujours la même
chose qui est qui est entendue par tout
ça hein donc du coup n'hésitez pas une
fois que vous avez commencé un peu à
explorer un peu à regarder différentes
lectures complémentaires euh que je vous
ai mis elles sont plutôt en anglais mais
à la fin du chapitre vous aurez du coup
euh un renvoi vers vers vers différents
outils notamment l'article marginalia de
Andrew Weiss je l'avoue c'est ça m'a
beaucoup aidé à un moment donné à bien
comprendre en fait les les les les
changements de vocabulaire
euh mais vous avez aussi euh euh le un
petit papier qui est the marginal effect
zo voilà ce qui est ce qui est important
à retenir en fait c'est que il y a ça
bouge encore je pense que le vocabulaire
n'est pas tout à fait stabilisé certains
d'entre vous connaissent peut-être
margins pour ceux qui viennent de stata
stata qui fait des contrastes marginaux
avec le package margins qu'on retrouve
aussi en fait hein c'est des contrastes
marginaux à la moyenne vous avez un ta d
margins qui est là mais le package
margin est beaucoup moins bon que le
package marginal effect euh mais voilà
retenez que c'est de plus en plus
présent le vocabulaire peut varier un
petit peu en économétrie en
épidémiologie ou en sociologie euh peut
aussi varier d'un auteur à l'autre d'un
package à l'autre euh donc c'est pour ça
que c'est important de de comprendre les
concepts et faut pas hiter à creuser un
peu et c'est vrai que c'est des choses
qui on voit monter de plus en plus et
qui sont de plus en plus fréquents si
vous avez des questions là-dessus je
vous invite à ne pas me écrire par email
directement euh de pas laisser de
commentaires dans YouTube parce que
souvent les commentaires Youtube je les
vois que tardivement et je n'y réponds
pas très bien le mieux en fait c'est de
poser un commentaire sur euh les les
pages de chapitre de guide air hein vous
avez des commentaires en dessous de
chacun des chapitre d'une part parce que
ça je le vois tout de suite et en
général j'y réponds assez rapidement euh
mais aussi parce que l'avantage c'est
que du coup si c'est un commentaire sur
le chapitre la réponse elle pourra aussi
bénéficier aux autres personnes ça sera
visible aux gens qui sont derrière alors
que si vous envoyez un message personnel
ça ne profiterait qu'à vous euh sachez
aussi que je ne suis pas votre
enseignant donc il y a des fois je ne
peux pas répondre à vos questions à la
place de la personne qui vous encadre je
ne connais pas non plus tout il y a des
des autres sujets que je connais pas
bien et surtout quand vous posez une
question euh donne un exemple concret
reproductible euh en me disant j'ai eu
un problème avec ça me permet pas moi de
pouvoir comprendre d'où vient le
problème encore faut-il que vous disiez
euh précis ment ce que vous avez fait
voir mettez un petit morceau de code et
juste le morceau de code qui pose
problème pas tout votre script voilà en
tout cas euh bah j'espère que vous aurez
apprécié sur euh ce ce nouveau type de
format pour les webinaires he qui est on
va essayer de reprendre de temps en
temps faire quand même quelques vidéos
sur ce nouveau sujet euh j'ai bien envie
d'aborder avec vous aussi la question
des des contrastes ou la manière alors
cette fois-ci sur la manière de coder
des variables catégorielles dans les
dans les modèles euh de voir peut-être
un de revenir un peu sur des des choses
plus avancées en sélection de modèle ou
en ou ou en intt ou sur la les
interactions sachez que du coup sur
guider vous avez des contenus qui sont
actualisés par rapport aux anciennes
vidéos de webinaire et puis euh
euh et puis euh il y aura aussi
maintenant des des nouveautés sur les
modèles de comptage les modèles
d'incidence donc vraiment euh encore une
fois je vous invite n'hésitez pas à
aller lire euh guide air sur ce je vous
souhaite
une très bonne journée après-midi soirée
en fonction de l'heure à laquelle vous
m'écoutez et au plaisir de vous
recroiser prochainement au
revoir